ich will sie nicht
niedergründau in hessen-nassau jonas und
christina lernen deutschlands ländliche
seite kennen
und nicht nur das auf sie wartet auch
eine ganz besondere attraktion nimmt an
einem seifenkistenrennen teil und seid
schneller als der gegner
ein rennen was wäre ich denke das ist
etwas was ihnen das an aber das gut
einfach
ob das so richtig ist team nord ist
ebenfalls in der provinz aber wieder an
der nordseeküste ganz in der nähe von
wilhelmshaven
es ist ebbe das wasser hat sich
zurückgezogen
genau richtig für die nächste aufgabe
fordert in einem rennen den deutschen
schlick schlitten meister heraus holt
innerhalb von 15 minuten mehr alle aus
der reuse als euer gegner
und wer ist der schlitten meister in der
zwischenzeit findet im süd heraus was
ein seifenkistenrennen eigentlich ist um
teilnehmen zu können müssen sie sich
aber noch anmelden müsst ihr euch mit
der seifenkiste dann schubsen aus sieben
leute instanz 73
sofort machen sich die drei auf die
suche nach freiwilligen zum glück ist
das team schnell zusammengestellt
auf team nord wartet dagegen ein
besonderer wettkampf im wattenmeer
die organisatoren haben schlitten
mitgebracht reusen also kleine netze und
künstliche alle nach einer stunde ist
alles aufgebaut und der schlick
schlitten meister ist auch da
also die wettkampffläche steht wir
werden die vergleiche an den ersten
markierungs hütchen staaten mit dem
schlitten fahren bis zum zweiten dass in
ca 30 meter dort steht ein renner ab
laufen bis zur reise holen adel
rausschicken reingefahren wieder zurück
ihr setzt euch rein
ihr werdet angeschoben wenn ihr drin
sitzt flach machen darum das trinken
der unternehmer flasche abgenommen angst
kennt ihn süd nicht schon gar nicht vor
dem gegner
alles läuft nach plan
der start ist geglückt
team süd liegt deutlich in führung und
der zusammenstoß mit dem krankenwagen
ist auch gut ausgegangen
auch team nord ist bereit für die
herausforderung während sie den
deutschen meister schlagen
der ursprung von riesigen fischer aus
die sind echt mit diesem gefährt zu
ihren neuesten gefahren weit ins land
hinein haben die reusen hergemacht
empfang vom schlitten definiert und dann
wieder zurück zum festland schlick
schlittenfahren hat also eine lange
tradition
doch was ist das der meister liegt schon
zu beginn zurück
hat er seine gegner unterschätzt
mit einer solchen hose kann man aber
auch nicht trennen
jetzt übergibt martin rosendahl an
seinen kollegen
der holt den rückstand zwar wieder auf
aber es reicht nicht mehr damit hat auch
team nord das ticket gewonnen und geht
wieder in führung
es steht 5 zu 4